what's going on guys this is rob and i
felt like covering neil gaiman's
eternals and the reason why is because
looking at the trailer that we've seen
recently and really it looks like a lot
of the stuff that we're going to see in
the movie is going to be based on what
neil gaiman did in his eternals run now
here's the thing neil gaiman's eternals
is designed to kind of explain why it is
that we haven't seen the eternals for a
really long time in marvel comics
because this takes place during civil
war and prior to this point we really
hadn't seen the eternals for a while and
so it was a really really cool way to
kind of fold this in so what this does
is it initially picks up with a guy by
the name of mark curry now this guy has
what are basically kind of like these
flashback memories these moments where
he experiences something from his past
but he's not really sure what it is and
even for him it seems like kind of a
nightmare now this will become important
later on down the line when he kind of
when we kind of get like the backstory
and everything but what he's basically
having dreams of is the war between the
eternals and the deviants and then the
arrival of the celestials in the middle
of that war and what was basically the
great cataclysm right the sinking of
atlantis and so this is cool because in
the middle of all this he suddenly met
by the arrival of icarus now one thing
to know is that icarus doesn't fully
know who he is right and that's going to
become a major plot point throughout
this video at least this kind of being
the first part of the story we'll cover
the second part in the second video
icarus doesn't fully know who he is mark
curry doesn't fully know who he is so a
lot of this is really just kind of
discovery right now icarus has a much
better idea of who he is than mark curry
does but that's why he keeps saying like
have you ever wondered where humanity
came from and different things like that
the reality is that icarus looks like a
crazy guy but he shows up at this dude's
hospital first and foremost like
pestering him talking about hey man like
have you ever wondered where everything
in existence came from you ever wonder
who made everything that's there it's
what you would expect like a jehovah's
witness to show up on your doorstep and
ask at like seven o'clock in the morning
right are you prepared for the
celestial's return
that kind of a thing and he even shows
up on the guy like like outside the
guy's apartment right outside his
brownstone in new york right knocking on
his window and asking him like hey or
have you thought anything about what
i've told you you know have you ever
wondered about the origins of
intelligent life on this planet it's
just kind of crazy stuff now at that
point you switch over to cersei and
cersei of course is kind of living out
this life where she is pretty awesome
right it's just cersei doing cersei
stuff you get this little bit of a tour
with regards to these eternals who are
basically here living out their lives
all the while seemingly completely
oblivious to the fact that they are
actually eternal they don't seem to know
who they are they don't seem to know
what they're capable of or what they can
do the closest thing that you really get
here is this moment where you kind of
have a sort of session between athena
and icarus but it really seems to be
just kind of a general discussion
between the two while they do look like
eternals it almost kind of seems to be a
flashback to a degree and so one of the
things that happens is that in the
middle of all this icarus is suddenly
attacked by these two just guys right
look like thugs that kind of a thing
they will become
very important later on in the story but
for right now they're just a couple of
guys who are giving you know icarus a
hard time in fact they actually throw
him down into a net and then throw a
bomb down there with him and then try to
blow him up but at that point you switch
over to ivan druid right now ivan drew
at this point in time is really kind of
a military slash representative of a
nation known as verazeka i think is how
you pronounce it or vorazega whatever it
is it's one of the former soviet
countries right those you guys weren't
really familiar with that back when you
had the ussr like during and after world
war ii you had what was essentially just
a whole bunch of of smaller countries
which have been conquered by the soviet
union and they were all just kind of
unified under the banner of the ussr
with the collapse of the soviet union
the fall of the berlin wall and all that
kind of stuff nikita khrushchev losing
all his power that what you had what was
basically the soviet bloc dismantling
and so a lot of those countries that had
previously been really ruled by the
soviet union had now become
self-governing and so in the marvel
comics basically vorzeka is one of those
places right so in the real world there
were a lot of them that were there so a
lot of them just haven't recovered but
the important thing is that's where this
place comes from now the reality of this
is again much like the other people who
are here druid does not know who he is
instead his working with cersei is kind
of interesting because they've known
each other for like a million years but
they don't know that they've known each
other for a million years and that's why
they're talking like strangers
instead the idea here is to work with
cersei to actually organize a party uh
that's basically going to be held at the
embassy of vorzeka for the purpose of
helping to kind of drum up tourism to
show people this is a place where they
want to travel to it's really geared
more towards the rich and the powerful
right because when it comes to any
organized society specifically american
society if the rich and the powerful do
it those who are not rich and powerful
will likely follow suit in order to
appear rich and powerful or to kind of
get a taste of the lives of the rich and
the powerful and so it's a pretty smart
move if only for diplomatic reasons but
following that you switch over to mark
curry who basically responds to the
emergency room uh emergency room call
anyway about this guy who basically is
supposed to be blown up he should be
dead right this guy's got fractures he's
got he's got you know burns and all
kinds of stuff only to find out that
it's icarus you switch over momentarily
to tony stark to iron man as he meets
with athena now iron man and athena have
a very lengthy history together but
again like the other eternals tina
doesn't really know who she is instead
as she's performing these kind of weapon
experiments creating a bomb that can
blind people things like that that it
all comes to her exceedingly easily
because whilst while it is basically in
her nature to do it she doesn't realize
it right so it's like if you spoke
spanish all your life and then forgot
that your ability to learn spanish would
be much much easier than a person who's
never learned spanish in their life
because what you're doing is basically
drawing on your subconscious right
you're drawing on something you already
know you just don't know that you know
it and so because of this athena kind of
makes this off-handed remark that it was
really really easy you know just like
remembering but this little bit of an
exchange will become important later but
switching back over to icarus this is
when you get at least a partial spilling
of the beans with regards to everything
it's kind of funny the way this happens
because when i was reading through this
i was like okay one of two things is
happening either icarus doesn't remember
how things were supposed to happen or
neil gaiman's messing with us
neil gaiman's changing things up so
icarus is going to give us the
explanation here but i'm going to kind
of fill you in on how things actually
are but right now the way that icarus
says this is about somewhere around a
million years ago that the celestials
had arrived on earth now for those of
you guys who are familiar with all of
this because we have talked about it
before bear with me because i think a
lot of people are going to be seeing
this and have no idea what's going on
here but about a million years before
the modern day the celestials showed up
on earth now the celestials visiting
earth was part of a grand cosmic
experiment right they literally did it
across the entirety of the universe in
more recent years especially during al
ewing's ultimates marvel sort of shifted
up the origins of the celestials
themselves which it might behoove us to
do an updated origins of the celestials
video uh just because of the fact that a
lot of significant things have changed
what al uwing did doesn't really have a
bearing on what's happening here uh so
that's why we'll probably make a
separate video but the important thing
is that as the celestials came into
existence or really entered into this
universe they spread across the whole
universe and basically seeded worlds now
depending on what story you're talking
about neil gaiman's keeping it pretty
contained here one of the things that
that marvel's done over the years is
introduced the idea that everything that
exists in the universe outside of the
cosmic entities and galactus right so
all the solar systems all the galaxies
all the planets stars all that kind of
stuff that was all created by the
celestials other people have said and
other writers have said that those
things just kind of formed naturally as
they do in a universe and all the
celestials did is exactly what you see
them doing here showing up on worlds and
seeding it with life regardless of how
you slice it though the important thing
is that whether the celestials seeded
these worlds with life or life already
existed the celestials would travel
around the universe to different worlds
and they would experiment on the
denizens of that world in the case of
earth what had happened is the
celestials had basically taken a group
called the wonders now one of the things
that neil gaiman is leading out here and
it's probably pretty intelligent to do
this is that technically if you go and
you read the old jack kirby eternal
stuff that it was actually gaia the
sentience of earth and the biological
mother of thor that had led these
individuals to the celestials themselves
but the thing about this is the
celestials basically took a small
portion of humanity at the time and they
split them into thirds and then
following that they started modifying
their genes one third of humanity had
their genes augmented so they would
basically achieve god-like power and
that's where the eternals came from the
ability to tap into cosmic energies and
essentially do anything they want to as
well as immortality insofar as if their
physical body is destroyed they can be
brought back they can be resurrected
essentially what you had is the eternals
just kind of created an existing as an
absolute number that could never grow
beyond the existing number that were
created by these celestials now with the
second third of humanity's genes being
destabilized that created the deviance
the big difference here between the
eternals and the deviants is that the
eternals all essentially look alike the
deviants are all completely different so
it'd be like if i took 100 of you guys
and i modified your genes and then
basically turned each one of you into a
different race that was completely and
totally different than any of the other
races around you the big kicker to this
and neil gaiman doesn't really explain
how somehow they managed to find a way
to procreate now because they were able
to do that they spread across the world
so fast their numbers increased by the
millions now neil gaiman kind of ends it
there and basically says like there was
a great big war that broke out between
the eternals and the deviants and so on
and so forth so let's fill in a few gaps
right let's kind of expand this a little
bit and offer some more explanation in
terms of the things that he doesn't
cover here so one of the things to know
is that the last third of humanity had
their genes modified so that at some
future point in time they would develop
powers and that's how marvel explains
why it is that bruce banner was just
like hit with gamma radiation and
instead of becoming this giant mass of
irradiated tumors like he did in marvel
ruins that instead he becomes the
incredible hulk it explains why it is
that some kid in a classroom somewhere
can go through a heightened level of
stress or start entering into puberty
and then suddenly an x gene activates
and they're just another mutant out
there now because of the fact that
humanity or at least that third of
humanity didn't have powers at that
point in time what it led to was the
deviants essentially subjugating them
right conquering them and then turning
them into a kind of slave labor during
that time the war between the eternals
and the deviants broke out and the
deviants operated out of the capital
city of lumeria in atlantis and so when
this giant war took place and the
eternals realized how hopelessly
outnumbered they were that they couldn't
continue fighting the deviants without
risking being destroyed themselves that
what they did is they contacted the
celestials and the celestials returned
only to find out the deviants had
basically deviated away from the role
that was originally created for them by
the celestials now the eternals did the
same thing right it wasn't until this
war broke out that the eternals cared
about what was going on with humanity
when the deviants struck first that's
when the eternal started getting
involved and so what you saw was the
great cataclysm the celestials basically
annihilating the deviants almost to the
point of complete and total extinction
they reduced their numbers down to a few
thousand and their population never came
back from that and then in turn it
allowed humanity to flourish because the
celestials then turned to the eternals
and said if you basically move away from
protecting humanity again we'll destroy
you all right we will we'll wipe
everything out we'll cleanse the whole
world and we'll call it a day now this
is kind of the explanation of how it all
took place right this great big conflict
that initially unfolded and so that's
why you have icarus basically speaking
with uh with mike curry and saying your
name is actually makari that's your real
name here and the idea is that we as
eternals once the deviants were
basically defeated and we essentially
started following what it was the
celestials told us to do we started
shepherding humanity we taught them how
to grow how to flourish we taught them
how to how to plant grain we taught them
how to work with metals we taught
society everything it would need to
become productive and this is the marvel
explanation as to how it is that the
capital city of lumeria in atlantis and
the earth itself could be such a
gigantic thriving you know place right
with all kinds of trade and commerce and
you know advanced technologies and
things like that and then after the
great cataclysm humanity essentially
appeared to start over again because it
did right humanity was pushed to the
near brink of extinction baseline humans
are really the only ones left the
deviants had basically gone underground
and because humanity had largely been
used as a kind of a slave labor force
they weren't really properly educated
and so during that time you know during
this whole era it really was almost like
starting from zero so it's very
aristotelian right in terms of how this
whole thing goes down but with this
whole explanation being given to uh to
makari he's kind of okay this is crazy
talk right like none of what you're
telling me makes any sense whatsoever
and it seems absolutely ridiculous and
so what actually ends up happening is a
couple guys show up the same guys that
actually tried to blow him up uh they
seem to show up here and then of course
he's handed over to those guys with
makari not really knowing what it is
that he's doing and so during that time
a few things unfold the first is that
makari continues to kind of endure these
sort of flashbacks to a degree but while
icarus is being held captive he actually
telepathically communicates with makari
asking him to find a way to free him to
save him and to get him out of there
because those guys are essentially going
to kill him as far as cersei goes while
she's there doing her thing at this
great big huge party what you have is
actually druid and a lot of people who
are who are present here and the whole
thing pops off when like these armed
terrorists come running in start
attacking the place snatching up the
scientists with the intention of racing
off and and so on and so forth and
during that whole time you actually have
what is in effect the formation of a
unimod now the unimon forming here is
really kind of a smaller version of what
it normally is and for those of you guys
who don't know what that is the unimide
is something you only ever really see
when eternals come together due to the
fact that like a gigantic decision needs
to be made and no one eternal is
equipped to make it on their own so say
for example that like something happened
the deviants had like overran the world
there was no way for the eternals to get
a hold of the celestials and they said
okay we have to like obliterate the
earth you know in order to stop the
deviants from like spreading into the
cosmos or something something like that
i don't know i'm just using some example
what would happen here is they would
form the unimine to one know whether it
was actually the right decision to make
and two if it were the decision that
they made blood would be on all their
hands because they made it as a singular
cohesive unit and so with that being the
case because this minor unimine is
formed a handful of things happen the
first is that mike curry realizes he is
makari that he can move at hyper speed
and so following that what you end up
doing is switching over to iron man who
basically you know appears on the scene
right in the midst of all this chaos and
all this insanity and the funny thing is
that while cersei has woken up to this
idea that there seems to be something
going on with her to a degree realizing
what's happening she doesn't fully grasp
it instead what actually ends up
happening here is iron man takes cersei
to the side seems to say something to
her and then basically leaves now the
reality of this is there are some people
here that have powers but none of them
want to act and the reason why is
because most anybody here who has powers
is likely unregistered remember this
takes place during the events of civil
war or really in the aftermath of civil
war tony stark's essentially one he's
director of shield but superhuman
registration is still in effect and so
if you are an unregistered superhero you
can either register or you can be thrown
into the prison in the negative zone
where you'll just be left to rot
basically and so because of that none of
these guys really want anybody to know
that they have powers but the crazy
thing is a lot of this is really kind of
coming from makari who's basically
recounting everything that's going on
here and the funny thing about this is
that this whole recollection of what's
been going on seems to be in the process
of being recounted to sprite now the
crazy thing about this is we don't
definitively know that it's sprite right
in fact we'll find out a little bit more
about that here in a second but
regarding these two guys who had
kidnapped icarus and are basically
torturing him and experimenting on him
you end up finding out that of course
these guys are deviants more so than
that what they're actually doing is they
are reading from what's called the book
of krask and this is particularly
important because what this book says is
that and then the golden one the
greatest of all the celestials he who
had created the changing people at times
dawn he who rose up against his fellows
let my people be he said for did i not
give them dominion over the earth and
all that is upon it but the other
celestials turned on him and tricked him
they swore to him that they would leave
the changing people in peace they were
oath breakers then and thus it is
written the oath of a celestial is
written on the winds of space and he's
shown like the sun but after they
betrayed him he was blacker than tar
they buried him for they could not kill
him beneath the earth our dreadlord lies
dreaming yet all things change and so
what these guys are basically talking
about is the dreaming celestial right
tiamu or tiamat it depends on who you're
talking to i always call them tiamou the
dreaming celestial here's something to
understand this guy is powerful with
dreaming celestials on a whole different
level than virtually anybody else that
you've seen in involving the celestials
themselves like in this hierarchy of
celestials this guy's way beyond them
now there are a couple things that
happen here that are worth mentioning
but are not overly important for example
druid realizes because he can kind of
manipulate the minds of others by
basically screwing with their memories
or their experiences tormenting them by
their own life history that what he does
is start to realize he could rise
through the ranks and actually rule this
country that he represents the second
thing that happened is he actually
orchestrated the terrorist attack but
instead of simply just kidnapping the
scientists that one of the people that
was working alongside him turned against
him so when he visits this guy he
basically tells this guy to kill himself
and that's essentially it but then you
switch over to thena of course is being
held as one of the scientists by this
you know this this group essentially led
by druid himself and during this this
whole event where she's being held
captive she suddenly realizes how deadly
she is right that she can use anything
as a weapon because she's the most
prodigious fighter of all the eternals
it's the reason why in marvel comics in
the early days of humanity during the
days of like greek gods and all that
kind of stuff athena was oftentimes
considered to be the earthly embodiment
of athena right the greek goddess of
like you know conflict or war wisdom or
whatever it is that she was known for
but the important thing is that fina
immediately starts realizing on who she
is right okay so like i'm fina i'm an
eternal i'm basically the best fighter
of all the eternals so she immediately
contacts tony stark knowing who he is
and she's like can you home in on this
number he's like yeah she's like get
here as fast as you can so he basically
races over there takes all these guys
out gets a hold athena and then
basically flies off icarus after having
essentially been killed is properly
resurrected and so now that he's
properly resurrected the actual
resurrection process takes place insofar
as all his memories of everything are
restored to him now that's an important
thing that happens when it comes to the
eternals it's something that kieron
gillen's modified a little bit in recent
years during his eternals run but the
important thing here is that when an
eternal dies when they're resurrected
and they're brought back they're a clean
slate you can put anything in their
brains that you want to right like
icarus could come back and the machine
could be like actually you're the state
puff marshmallow man and we need you to
go attack new york right that's and he
would believe it right because he's
basically a shell right it's like
pouring water into a into a cup right
whatever you pour into that cup that's
what that cup will be a cup of milk a
cup of water a cup of tea and so because
of this it's a very very interesting
process but potentially also a dangerous
one the benefit here is that every ounce
of knowledge every experience that the
eternals have is backed up it's actually
what jonathan hickman essentially copied
when it came to kokoa in the x-men
comics right the fact that the x-men
back up everything that had happened to
every mutant across the world so long as
they've been to krakowa so that if they
happen to be resurrected they have their
memories up until that point they can be
changed and modified but they're
basically the same thing that that's
what's happening with icarus his
memories are being restored to him and
so as makari is spending time talking to
this little kid the first thing he asks
is like are you an eternal right this
kid's like no i'm not an eternal i
promise you like i am not an eternal i'm
a human right like i'm a human person i
have no powers no abilities whatsoever
which really begs the question how does
he know so much about the eternals
because he tells makari like touch that
black rock over there right we'll find
out if you're an eternal or not touch
that black rock and we'll see what
happens when he touches that rock
immediately this doorway opens and
basically lowers them down into uh into
this kind of you know basement type area
underground in san francisco and as this
kid talks to him right he's kind of like
okay so here's the thing the next test
of whether or not you're an eternal is
to attack that giant black wall over
there right like charge that thing as
fast as you can he's like for me i don't
do anything if i try to charge it but
you charge it and let's see what happens
and so like when makari goes to hit the
wall before he can even touch it he's
kind of pushed back by this this sort of
energy field and then is unable to
actually do anything to the rock and
that's when this kid starts messing with
him he's like god you guys are so such
idiots like that is not a giant black
rock that's the dreaming celestial right
that's how big the dreamy celestial is
this guy's miles tall but what this kid
reveals is that he is actually sprite
and the reason why the eternals can't
remember anything is because of what
sprite did that when the celestials
showed up on earth in the early days
right like a million years ago and they
modified the genes of one-third of
humanity and made them eternals one of
them was sprite that he was a kid whose
genes were modified he was given
god-like powers the issue with this is
that by and large with the eternals
their evolution is frozen in place
they'll never grow right they'll never
get older they are by all standards of
measurement immortal and perfect and so
the biggest issue that uh that sprite
had with this is he will never age what
really pissed him off is that apparently
like cersei has just like banged
everybody right she's like he's like
yeah man like every single like eternal
dude she slept with somewhere along the
line he's like but she'll never sleep
with me because i'm like 11.
he even approached her at one point and
tried to see if she wanted to knock
boots and she was like no i mean you're
11. that's that's not going to happen
and so ultimately that combined with the
fact that he's been 11 years old for a
million years was enough for him to just
not want to have anything to do with
this the only thing he could really do
was find enjoyment and messing with
people right so like showing up to a guy
in 1901 out on a park bench and claimed
to be peter pan and actually setting the
stage for the story that became peter
pan right like the character of peter
pan in in literature it's based off of
uh sprite basically messing with a guy
right all that kind of stuff and so the
idea here of sprite was to essentially
strip down and to eliminate the
possibility of eternals being what they
are and to actually revert them back to
humans but that's not something you can
easily do if sprite had kind of jumped
into a campaign using his ability to
create illusions and said actually we're
all humans and called it a day it never
would have worked instead what happened
here is that there was a scenario where
a unimined was formed and sprite was
part of it right it was necessary for
sprite to be a part of this unimine in
order to basically fix you know the
aftermath of this giant earthquake and
and so on and so forth the important
thing here is that sprite realized given
the power of the unimine because it can
alter the genetic structure the memories
the whole nine yards of eternals he can
use that to his own ends and so over the
course of
years and we're not really given a
definitive amount of time we're told
that it's like thousands and thousands
of years that what he did is he actually
began to manipulate the eternals so when
an eternal died and they were brought
back he would make a modification to
their memories here that when another
eternal died and they were brought back
he'd make a modification there if they
die and come back enough times suddenly
this entire memory bank that they have
right everything they recall is full of
false memories that's what he says he's
like in a hundred years there's a lot of
illusion that you can create you can
give people memories that aren't theirs
you can make them forget things they
always knew you can make people forget
things that are true and believe things
that are not a little illusion goes such
a long way he says it took a whole lot
of work and he's talking about more work
than he ever would have believed to have
been possible but he said when i was
done i went down to the reactivation
chamber i took xeros the most powerful
of us ajax the only one who could talk
to the celestials and i brought them
here i couldn't make the archive
reactivate them fully without bringing
back all the frozen dead but it was
enough what he did here is he basically
took xeros and he took ajac he brought
them here to the dreaming celestial and
then he performed a unimod using those
two eternals and the dreaming celestial
which basically gave him the power to do
anything he wanted to he and that's one
of the things he says like i could have
done anything i wanted to i could have
made snow taste like chocolate right i
could have have made the rivers run red
i could have done anything that i wanted
to in existence but the only thing i
ever wanted to do was to be human and so
using the power of the dreaming
celestial he essentially stripped away
the eternal's knowledge of who they were
and then reduced them down to being
humans and so that's one of the crazy
things here is that because of that
everything that's happening here has all
been done at the hands of sprite the
greatest rouge that sprites ever done
more so than that what you actually end
up doing is switching over to icarus
when he goes to see thena and once tina
begins to really understand who she is
all these memories of her actual life as
an eternal start flooding back she's met
by the arrival of icarus and he's like
he just kind of hangs there for a second
and then he's like do you know who i am
and she says yes and he says we have to
go now and when she asks where he says
it's the deviants they're going to wake
the dreaming celestial and if they do
they will kill the world and they will
when the dreaming celestial or if the
dreaming celestial ever were to wake up
and it does things are crazy to give you
guys a little bit of a taste of what
we're gonna cover in this next video
when the dreaming celestial wakes up
there's one line in the comic where it
says that like the universe shakes in a
way that it hasn't done in millions of
years and for the first time in a long
time galactus knows what it's like to
feel fear it's crazy right it's
absolutely awesome with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace
you